[Music]
Excitement is cute because we are friends
[Laughs]
I know
a
lot  I tend to think that if you give and
really love you,
you can feel it
.
I think I really liked
that meme of pretending to drink water like that and showing off my abs.
I
think it's cool I have something like that. Edit our songs and
paste the moments I've staged so far to make a video
. I saw a little bit of it.
That friend's Square
Times Square Or Feed, not Buzz
Nurungji I've thought of Nurungji with a more foreign feel, but I think I'm a
poodle
[Applause]
[Music]
I really like Blast's song.
I like riding the rhythm
[Music]
I don't want to cry, I don't want to cry,
please play me a song called I'm pretty
[Music]
Guys, what if I step on it? Don't step on it
.
Don't step
on it.
[Music] For the
rest of my life, I'm cute. I
like cute things, so I'm also cute.
People have to be lovable. That's right.
[Music]
These days, I look at a lot of meal kit apps.
What kind of sensitivity did you take these things in the
app
[Music] I did
a lot of giblet hot pot in New York
. I think the
pizza was so delicious.
I've had a lot of work before. I've been to the steak house where we had dinner
. It's delicious. The meat
tastes like steak.
[Music
] How about a unit like this?
I enjoyed the tour
well and I think I had a good time during my break, and
later I stepped on [ __ ] like I want to go to prettier and nicer
places in the US, take a lot of pretty pictures,
and travel more leisurely
.  I think I want to live in the woods once. I like to
build a villa in the woods. I like it. I build a
villa and
drink coffee. The
feeling of wanting to live in nature in a leisurely way. Like I want to live
while breathing good air.
Future of
K-pop, but it wasn't.
I think it was really fun
[Music]
To be honest, my debut stage
fell apart so
I
tried several stages,
but I'm embarrassed now because of the desire to show off my debut stage better, but that's why
I can shake everything that was a bit difficult, so now it's
already passing by  It's work, so I do
n't think there was anything
difficult for me.  I was able to develop, so
I think that difficulty is a very good difficulty. I think it's
the hardest when I'm sleepy. Whether I do everything
[Music]
Thank you,
adopt me. Adopt me
[Music]